today we're going to talk about my two
cats lady C and persistance
okay
their real names are Ava and Georgia for
those of you know that the Gabor sisters
this might be a question but it'll
depend on dr. raccoon yellow he sort of
said how are you gonna work this in and
I said I'll find a way
1962 Neil Sedaka's recorded a song which
was breaking up is hard to do and that's
really the essence of what we're going
to talk about today we're going to talk
about what happens and what are some of
the effects of virus long term
infections persistent infections where
virus particles are made to some extent
latent infections where sometimes
virtually nothing is made sometimes a
few proteins but perhaps the most
amazing part of latent infections is the
fact that for the most part the virus
finds a place in the host where it can
lay dormant for the life of that animal
in our case it's men so breaking up that
is clearing the virus is an
extraordinarily difficult event in some
cases never happens in most cases and
even when it does happen we don't know
that we've cleared the infection and
that pertains to the hepatitis viruses
okay so we heard a little bit about
acute infections and persistent
infections from dr. Acula last week and
to make life simple it doesn't hurt to
go over it again and I want to remind
you that an acute infection is a natural
infection that is usually rapid and
self-limiting you get hit you get sick
you're better
persistent infections on the other hand
our natural infection that can be
long-term in nature so it's slow viruses
tend to replicate over a long period of
time sometimes they're abortive the
virus doesn't complete its replication
cycle sometimes the virus associates
with a host and something happens in its
genetic information is disrupted and
sometimes they're transforming events
that is they cause cells to become
malignant
you saw this last week as well and I
want to go over it just briefly and
remind you that the acute infections are
short in duration virus replication and
symptoms occur replication occurs before
symptom ology almost always in all cases
we have some instances of long-term
persistent infections such as
lymphocytic or meningitis virus and it's
just sort of smaller's and it stays
there and it does really bad things to
you and over a period of time if you're
a mouse you die and then you have herpes
simplex virus which is present in really
all of you whether you like it or not
and that's a persistent infection that
lays latent in dormant in your neurons
in your ganglia in both your parents and
in both your sympathetic and sensory
neurons and the hallmark of herpes
simplex virus inside the megaload virus
for that matter too is what we call
recrudescence infections and that's
waves periodic waves where the virus is
reactivated and sheds and you have a
noticeable manifestation a cold store
for instance in the case of chickenpox
virus varicella
it's shingles in the case of CMV it's
usually silent but the virus is highly
infectious in the case of
varicella-zoster virus we don't see any
in apparent shedding like we do with
herpes simplex virus so there are people
who are carrier you're all carriers
ordinary but there are people who have
herpes simplex virus and transmit it
without signs of overt lesions
and those are shedders so we see that
wave and then there are these persistent
infections that are very very slow such
as the measles association with SSP and
we'll go briefly through that again
today HIV infection and dr. R Candela
will address that in greater detail
later and the human Tila Futaba virus
which is a relative of the HIV okay with
viruses such as Rhino influenza and even
HIV there were small changes that occur
because these are RNA genomes and the
replication machinery is not perfect and
the resulting viruses are selected and
they're selected for small changes in
antigenic variation and they survive and
that leads to shedding of areas that are
resistant to clearing because whatever
antibodies are made are not effective so
in some cases infections can linger on
longer and that's antigenic drift of
small changes and selection process that
allows for the viruses to escape
persistent infections occur when primary
infection is not cleared by the adaptive
immune response so everything that we've
learned about that's so good and that
works so well doesn't always work so
well depending upon when the immune
system is activated and how vigorous
that response is an infection may or may
not be cleared and what happens then is
that virus genomes which shouldn't be
its virus genomes and or proteins
continue to be produced for years there
are instances of viruses that are
persistent such as hepatitis B and
hepatitis C where viruses are produced
for years so the liver is infected and
virus is constantly produced and yet the
virus remains and it remains immune to
the host now what's the difference
between a chronic and a latent infection
chronic infections which are persistent
infections are eventually cleared
so eventually something happens the host
developed some sort of reasonable immune
response and removes the infected cells
from the population of whatever organ
that might be however in the case of
latency that's not what happens in the
case of latency those virus genomes
persist for the lifetime of the
individual and where they persist in
what organ what the target tissue is
varies for various viruses what are some
of the general properties of latent
infections well gene products promoting
replication are generally not made and
that's a generalization and of course
like everything else in biology it's not
an absolute everything that we say is an
absolute turns out and off to be gene
products that are made or found in very
low concentration oops
and when they are found whoops and when
they are found they're frequently in the
wrong place so instead of being where
the virus can use those proteins either
to replicate or to transcribe or to
transmit some aspect of its protein
repertoire it's just not there cells of
latent genomes are masked from immune
surveillance they're hidden and viral
genomes persist intact to reactivate and
spread to a new host so the virus is not
there to die
it's not there to go into that
particular tissue that particular cell
type to never come out it really wants
to reactivate and the only exception
that we know about is measles and sspe
where the entire measles genome is not
present only parts of it survive and
they encode these proteins that are
passed from cell to cell and cause sspe
okay so what are some examples of latent
infections one that we'll talk about is
the epstein-barr virus
it's the causative agent of mona
nucleosis the causative agent of
nasopharyngeal carcinoma
it's the causative an agent of
a proliferating b-cell lymphoma and
Hodgkin's disease and that's enough all
right and when the virus is latent it
has novel transcription and replication
patterns and generally it makes no new
virus but it has three different forms
of latency and we'll talk about those in
a little more detail later on and
different transcription profiles to
match those three different forms what
is interesting is that the genome
replicates and the reason that the
genome has to replicate is that it can't
be partitioned to another cell that is
if the cell divides it can't go with it
if it doesn't replicate otherwise it
gets diluted out think about that we'll
go through that example a couple of
times today if you only remain in the
cell that you infect then the cells
divide eventually there are more
daughter cells than there are
progenitors adenovirus is most
frequently associated with terrible
upper respiratory illnesses can be
isolated from lymphoid tissue the
adenoids in the back of your throat and
tonsils so the viruses there at very
very low levels and can persist lately
and when you take those tissues out you
find that most of the virus is actually
present in lymphocytes in those organs
when your culture the organs in tissue
culture you can't get virus out they
don't produce virus so that tells you
something about the milieu in which the
virus sits and the cells in which it
sits and how there must be some
contributory factors some relationship
between the virus and where it is in the
host that allows it to replicate at a
very very low level and persist here's
an extensive table from your book and it
points out a bunch of interesting things
and it tells you that for example
hepatitis B can be found in the liver in
lymphocytes and the consequences of it
being there long time
a fulminate infection of the liver and
later hepatocellular carcinoma and we
believe that one leads to the other
as a result of inflammation so you see
the tie-ins to all the things that Vince
and I have been talking about over the
last couple of weeks and how viruses
elicit immune responses and sometimes
what the host does really screws things
up herpes simplex virus are found in
sensory in order nama ganglia and when
they erupt they form cold sores or
genital herpes papilloma viruses are
found in epithelial cells and they found
predominantly in the basal layer of the
replicating epithelium and the squalor
of long-term infection is papillomas not
caused by frogs but by virus and
carcinomas and that depends on the type
of virus that you're infected with so
there are over a hundred different types
and we'll get onto that in a little
while and then more recently it's become
very apparent to us that there are a
family of human polyomavirus and two of
them are on this chart and I'll talk
about another one that was found four
years ago which is yeah I think it's
more interesting than these two but they
lay in the kidneys in the central
nervous system at least JC does and they
for the most part dormant but it's been
noted that people who are
immunosuppressed for one reason or
another either because they're infected
with AIDS virus or because they're on an
immunosuppressive regime because they're
a transplant recipient frequently
develop a demyelinating disease called
progressive multifocal
leukoencephalopathy so you'll look HVS
to pronounce that at the final in UA act
or a hemorrhagic cystitis and these only
occur under conditions for the most part
of some sort of immune suppression so
think back about what Vin said the other
day about measles an immune suppression
there can be some other force in nature
which throws everything out of balance
I've told you about herpes simplex and
let me just move on to H CMV and you'll
see look at the just sheer number of
cell types in which this virus can
persist kidneys salivary glands
lymphocytes macrophages stem cells
stroma
sells its found in breast milk it's
found in semen it really gets around
alright and the real problems with it or
pneumonia and retinitis it can be very
dangerous to the newborn but anytime you
have a transplant patient and your
transplant an organ you have to test for
CMV and most of the time you really
don't have the time to do it so they
purge organs of lymphocytes and all
sorts of blood cells in the hopes to get
most of it out and most of the time they
do and sometimes they don't and if they
have an opportunity to test for it then
fine but if not what you can do is
introduce this virus into an individual
who probably already has the virus but
the difference is when you do a
transplant you and Minister pres and now
you're going to reactivate that virus
that's person then that's more frequent
than we'd like to and know about so how
do you promote persistence doesn't seem
like a really good thing for the body to
do but it does it anyway well sometimes
the innate immune system fails to clear
an acute infection and that's one way in
which can happen sometimes because the
virus is blocking the ptosis which we
talked about last week that can lead to
persistence it allows the virus to
become stable and associate and remain
with the infected cell what are the host
contributions to persistence well the
two tissues that are a void of
initiators and effectors of the immune
system are the eyes and the neurons so
while you have immune responses the
initiators really are for the most part
not working up the snuff and so they
turn out to be a great place to start if
infection because the vigorous immune
response would be detrimental to the
host
you'd be blind if you had a really good
immune response to some of the viruses
that infect your eye and frequently
people do get blind from them so a CMV
retinitis or herpes simplex virus
retinitis where I had no virus retinitis
a role really dangerous disease to those
would get them and most of them can be
treated with antivirals
so these organs tend to be persistently
infected as a result of the fact that
the immune response is somewhat
decreased so how does the virus genome
exist in these infected organelles I've
put up three states and we'll talk about
most of them and one of them is a non
replicating genome in a non dividing
cell so you all know that neurons don't
divide and both herpes simplex virus and
varicella-zoster virus or viruses that
get into neurons somehow or other they
make copies of themselves and it remains
a mystery to most of us who have studied
it and they persist in the neurons at
about fifty copies per cell they persist
as episome a-- units that is they're
free of the host chromosome and there's
no evidence that they replicate in other
cases we have autonomous
self-replicating chromosomes in a
dividing cell human papillomaviruses in
basal cells of the developing epithelium
hepatitis C and B in liver cells and
epstein-barr virus in lymphocytes on
occasion these viruses can integrate
into the host chromosome and replicate
with the host HIV parvo virus the
single-stranded guys with the funny
Panhandle lens and human herpes virus
called hhv-6 which is a primary cause of
a mild childhood disease but an amazing
thing happens with its genome and we'll
discuss that in a little bit of detail
so let's talk about some of the
interactions that occur between viruses
and their house and interesting one is
thinnest virus and there's a model in
which you shove this virus into an adult
Mouse brain and you can get a persistent
non cytopathic infection so the virus
survives that event and so does the host
if you do the same thing into a neonatal
mouse brain you get a lethal infection
so in one case there's a symbiotic
infection if you will the virus survives
persists and the other case the host
dies as a result of infection why it's
all about where you are and when so in
the neonatal neurons like proteins that
block virus induced apoptosis and when
you pay Patos you die things to Krause
you send out signals you have a massive
inflammatory response and the animal
succumbs to the infection another virus
that provides an interesting paradigm is
bdv anybody know what that stands for
bovine something right okay there's a
bovine diarrhea virus and it's a pesty
virus and there are two strains of this
virus there's a cytopathic strain and a
non cytopathic strain and it turns out
that you can infect these animals in
utero as a natural course of events and
the non cytopathic virus will establish
a lifelong infection in cattle so it
will persist in the infected animal when
it's infected in utero these animals
have no detectable antibody or t-cell
response to virus antigens so they're
making virus the infected cells are
elaborating new viral proteins but
they're not being seen so what we say is
the host is tolerant
it's tolerant of what's going on and it
just lets it go because it's going on at
a slow low level when these animals are
infected with the cytopathic strain
though the interferon response is
activated and the virus is readily
cleared so two different strains getting
two different responses doctor joaquin
yellow talked about measles and SSP last
week so I'll go through it rather
quickly as you know there's no animal
reservoir for measles it's
extraordinarily contagious and if you
isolate the infection then you can stop
the spread there are 40 million cases a
year
and it leads to systemic in
immunosuppression so thus equality of
measles infection are more than just the
overt development of complex spots and
spots all over here the good thing is
that you develop lifelong immunity so
it's a great vaccine if that's the way
you want to be vaccinated the bad thing
is that there are serious problems with
those who are pregnant who acquire
measles and you saw this slide last week
as well where the normal infection leads
to giant cells and infect the tissues
spreads to the entire
reticuloendothelial system the virus
gets shed and then a secondary viremia
occurs and that's when you see the
development of disease and spots in rare
instances the virus gets to the brain
and there's an encephalitis second
develop and even more rare instances we
see the development of sspe where only
portions of the virus genome persist and
virus proteins are made and so what's
the hypothesis about how this works well
in the infected individual measles
enters the brain in infected lymphocytes
antibody blocks cell cell fusion so
because the lymphocytes are in you've
opened up the blood-brain Baur barrier
and the removal of fusion protein from
the surface allows for persistence of
portions of the virus all hypothesis
none of this is fact I mean this is fact
but we don't know that we don't know
that that's how it happens and then you
get a slow infection that goes on that's
not persistent low levels of envelope no
variance but nuclear protein complex is
spread from cell to cell
it's a cytoplasmic virus it's out there
it can go from cell to cell and after a
while
long-term accumulation of these nuclear
protein complexes leads to sspe and the
individual dies in six to eight years
I'm going to talk about herpes viruses
because they manifest themselves in a
large number of ways and elaborate sets
of different RNAs and different proteins
that are found under conditions of
latency so first we'll talk about herpes
simple well let's just talk about herpes
simplex virus here and I've told you
before that an unusual series of
transcripts originates from the genome
and latent ly infected cells and these
transcripts are called latency
associated transcripts or lats and
they're derived from a single region of
the chromosome and they accumulate in
the nucleus of the latent Lea infected
cell and what they are is a stabled
intron so normally they should be cut
out of a messenger RNA and they should
be degraded in the nucleus and they just
accumulate and nobody knows why it's
very close cousin varicella-zoster does
something entirely different
it's pathway of infection is similar
it's residency and the ganglia is
similar but it elaborates a small subset
of proteins and these proteins go to the
wrong place and normally found in the
nucleus they're involved in control of
virus replication and they're found in
the cytoplasm depending upon the type of
EBV latent infection certain virus
proteins and small viral RNAs like the
adenovirus VAR na EBV makes something
called Ebers eb e RS and they're small
rnas that have highly high highly
structured molecules and we believe that
they act much like micro rnas and
they're required to maintain the latent
state if you knock them out you don't
get latency and they're thought to
modulate the host response that is
whether or not the host sees the
infected cell how it sees this in fact
it's cell
BBV elaborates a il-10 mimetic and that
has effects on how the host sees it and
then 4-h CMV and kshv not only did they
tamper the hosts immune response and we
talked about the CMV weighs in at
nauseam last week but they also
elaborated micro rna's that are thought
to play a role in the establishment of
latency yes epstein-barr virus encoded
RNAs and their small highly structured
RNA molecules like the VAR days of
adenovirus okay so how do you get
cytomegalovirus I told you where it was
found and that should give you some
clues the virus can enter through the
eyes ocular infection can enter through
the oral pharynx it can enter through
sexual transsexual transmission and it
can be transmitted from a mother to a
child through breast milk so those are
various ways in which the virus can be
acquired it infects epithelial and other
cell types including some of the
lymphocytes most infections though or
subclinical you get the infection
there's no apparent display of illness
and you get over it cell mediated
immunity however is required for
resolution of infection and when the
virus establishes itself as a latent
genome in an infected cell it does it in
bone marrow progenitors and macrophages
so things that are going to be around
for a long time in the host and if you
repress some mediated immunity then what
you get is recurrence so once again that
relates the topic of why you bother to
deal with it in transplants and why it's
so important and all blood is typed for
CMV among god knows how many other
different viruses at this time
infection in utero can be devastating to
the fetus children infected in utero
frequently are born deaf have
intelligence defects have some anomalies
sometimes in limbs early childhood
infection less so once once the fetus is
formed the virus has less effect but the
virus does persist and it can be found
in salivary glands and in nurseries
where kids play with one another and
smear themselves with god-knows-what
secretions they transmit it amongst
themselves and there's some great
studies on this for those of you who
want to look them up and I've told you
before it's found in salivary glands
mammary glands and semen reactivation
can be with dire consequences and the
micro rna's that are expressed by seeing
the both in vitro when you take an organ
out of an animal and in vivo when seen
in the animal or tissue specific so
certain micro rna's are made in certain
organs and that's very cool so once
again pointing to the relationship
between the virus and the host and those
micro rna's are associated with specific
stages of virus infection in terms of
virus surviving virus being latent virus
being lytic virus reactivating alright
my first rule of latency that which
becomes leighton must reactivate
otherwise there's no advantage as the
virus can no longer spread so the fact
that a virus comes in and latent li
infects you it's not because that's
really what it wants to do that's a
survival mechanism becomes a passenger a
passenger for life that sometimes comes
back to haunt you herpes simplex virus
the population in the United States is
80 something percent Sarah positive for
either type 1 or type 2 that means 250
million of us have latent virus hiding
in our neural ganglia and 40 million at
any one time or in any one year will
experience recurrence and some
a cement asymptomatic shedder so when
that cold sore comes because it's finals
time it's because you are doing
something to activate that virus there
are stress molecules that are known
induces of virus among other things how
does the virus get to where it goes and
sometimes it sometimes it can cause
encephalitis
sometimes it's and that's a very rare
disease but most of the time it just
becomes resident in your neural ganglia
so the virus infects cells in the
epidermis either in the throat on your
actual skin through a small cut
replicates in these epithelial cells and
can spread from cell to cell when it
gets to the basolateral surface of the
epidermis it can then enter the
dendrites the longer extensions of your
sensory or your sympathetic neuron
bodies and then what the virus does is
it goes up that very very long act axon
finds itself very happily ensconced in
the neural body and replicates to some
extent and that's the black box of this
whole thing and that's one of the things
that we don't understand and that is why
are there multiple virus genomes present
in the nucleus of a cell that's not
being killed and is and really has no
capacity for DNA replication because
neurons don't replicate sometimes this
virus can spread up to the central
nervous system that's very very rare in
the case of the sympathetic neuron
you've got to have contact with yet
another neuron but in each case the
establishment is the same so one of the
post infection events in neurons we know
that the nuclear capsid that structure
inside the envelope travels up the axon
but we also know that the nucleic acid
is stripped of all those ancillary
proteins that surround at the tagamet
and so the viral
activator of transcription vp-16
is separated from the nucleocapsid so
it's a little bit of a mystery as to how
infection starts there is limited
productive infection we don't see late
proteins for the most part you see it
sometimes during the acute phase of a
ganglionic affection but once it becomes
latent you no longer see those and we
believe that local inflammation
astrocytes coming in lead to resolution
of the infection genome is silenced and
it's coated by nucleosomes so now it
looks like normal DNA inside the cell as
I said before there are multiple copies
of virus DNA anyway is between five and
fifty and what's true for simplex is
also true for varicella at least for
that and then we see the nuclear
accumulation of these latency associated
transcripts if you look in a mouse model
and you excite ride geminal ganglia at
different times post infection of the
eye and what they do is they scarify the
eye and they put a little bit of virus
in the eye of the mouse and then you
wait and first the virus replicates
locally in the eye and then it gets
transmitted through the trigeminal nerve
to the trigeminal ganglion and you see
with time the virus arrives the titer
increases it replicates and then by two
weeks
it's totally disappeared you can't
identify infectious virus inside those
ganglia
now when we talk about ganglia we talk
about thousands of neurons and many of
them are infected and when we talk about
reactivation only one or two of those
many actually reactivated so the virus
infection does not spread in the ganglia
from cell-to-cell what happens is the
virus reactivates it goes down that axon
and it erupts on the skin surface and
that's how you get a cold sore all right
what do lats do so the answer is I don't
know but this is what we do know Latin -
viruses so we can make those we can move
the sequences that encode them
reactivate very poorly there are two
open reading frames that are contained
in the LAT sequence but no known protein
has ever been associated with them so
there's no evidence that they get
translated or for that matter that these
become messenger rna's and get into the
cytoplasm they do however encode micro
RNAs and they encode micro rna's that
could inhibit expression of ICP zero a
potent transcriptional activator that's
the protein that takes apart the nd tens
PML complex in the nucleus and then
another protein called gamma 34.5 which
is a neuro virulence gene that activates
as you'll recall protein phosphatase one
so what it's doing is things that will
inhibit the expression of these guys
that will help establish virus infection
and when you look at the virus genome
and you do computational analysis
analysis of the structure what you see
is that most of the sequences that could
possibly encode micro RNAs are found in
the region of these lats or this
overlapping gene ICP 0 or 34.5 so these
two genes are transcribed from one
strand of DNA and the LAT complex from
another but in each case we find
multiple examples of micro rnas and the
other thing that we know is that while
there are similarities and differences
between hsv-1 and hsv-2 one is found
predominantly above the waist yet
there's found below the waist sometimes
the one below the waist is above the
waist that could be a question of her
you know how does that get there that
could be one of your final questions all
right but you can figure that out but
what's important is that their
evolutionary conserved so both viruses
have this same set of micro rnas and
they're probably used to regulate
expression of these gene products wine
neurons neurons are a great place to be
if you're a virus the DNA virus that
doesn't have to replicate you've got
multiple copies of yourself you're
primed to do something you really don't
know what all right but the cells
themselves don't replicate it divide the
GNote is
readily established and it persists
there's nothing there to take it apart
for the most part it's insensitive to
antivirals so treatment with antivirals
does not knock it down because
antivirals
generally are targeted to replicated
molecules no replication no effective
antivirals they're insensitive to immune
surveillance and they're not violated
for the most part whether because of the
blood-brain barrier but the question
remains how do they survive the primary
infection in any system in which we have
looked infection with a herpes virus of
one type or another where it replicates
kills the cells except in the case where
it establishes latency and what's
different about that how does it get
stopped how does the a patata program
get inhibited and why do these things
persist so why are there multiple copies
of virus DNA in cells that shouldn't
support virus replication I told you
that only a small number of neurons and
a ganglion reactivate and that tells you
that whatever the mechanism is that's
responsible for reactivation and how
those ganglia see or sense those signals
not all cells are equal so some of them
sense it and they do something that
allows the virus to reactivate reruns
appear in mucosal tissue that is
innervated by latent ly infected ganglia
and blisters and so so you can think
about it I don't know how many of you
have seen people with shingles
but shingles is the second coming of
aerosol it ain't pretty
the really nice thing about is is that
it's usually confined unilaterally only
one side of the body body into a single
dermatome so a dermatome is an area
that's innovated by a particular
ganglion and so that's why you see
swathes of infection infected pustules
along a normal course our back or of
course the
of a body okay I told you that what
happens to surrounding neurons is an
enigma the virus which has all these
beautiful little envelopes on it that
allowed to pass from cell to cell
doesn't do that in neurons so the
adjacent neuron doesn't get infected
unless the virus goes totally crazy so
their evidence is for example we've
looked at hundreds of ganglia over the
years where you can show that the virus
reactivates in situ and that's of course
the devastating thing but it usually you
have to remove that the tissues that we
deal with are acquired at autopsy and so
it turns out that if you remove a
ganglion from an individual and you wait
a certain amount of time the virus will
actually reactivate from that acts
atomized ganglia where it's not doing
quite as well in the host many times
reactivation is silent but virus is shed
so that's a problem for infecting
individuals and there are enough studies
on college campuses to demonstrate that
that's true how does the virus infection
mast from the hosts immune response why
is it that you don't even though you
have a great antibody titer you have
vigorous T cell immunity
you still get recrudescence you still
have virus coming out it may have
something to do with the proximity of
the dendrite to the epithelial surface
and that's conjecture but it's the only
thing that makes sense
cells touch and when cells touch and a
virus comes down this long pathway
there's very little instance where the
virus proteins are actually found on the
surface of the axons so the cell remains
hidden from the host what flips the
switch we know that stress is a great
reactivate er of herpes viruses we know
that glucocorticoids can reactivate we
know that sunlight in orange juice or
effect
of mediators of those of you who are
susceptible and in a model system we
know that if we express this virus gene
product we can reactivate but two years
ago there was a manuscript that was
published using mice as a model and this
manuscript demonstrated that a virus
protein this vp-16 the guy that is
present in the very unparticle the guy
that's responsible for initiating virus
infection and the protein that's made
late in the virus infection cycle
appears to be required and important for
reactivating virus under some sort of a
model system and that represents a
conundrum because it's thought to be a
late promoter but studies have
demonstrated that funny things happen in
neurons and this gene is probably turned
on early in response to exogenously
it's a tough experiment to do with
people you understand that but we'd love
to try ok so compare establishment
maintenance and reactivation we have our
primary infection with a virus the
introduction of its segment proteins
you've heard all about this before we
get a class of virus gene products that
are made immediately and they modulate
interferon in cytokine release so they
suppress the host a bit then we have
early genes that are expressed we get
DNA replication and a commitment to
productive growth and the inhibition of
ap ptosis so that the virus can complete
its replication cycle subsequently late
teens are expressed particles assemble
and DNA is packaged and in some
instances virus spreads from cell to
cell and some instances it's bit out of
the cell and it goes into the
bloodstream and you have a very Mia
particles regress infectious virus is
produced and then sometimes it goes into
a different kind of a cell and that's
your neuron in this case immediate early
early gene expression is blocked or we
believe it to be blocked Latins are
expressed those RNAs accumulate and
latent infection
is established viral gene products not
that we know that the only file gene
products are again are that RNA and the
accumulation of virus DNA viruses
maintain in its episome estate outside
the chromosome god bless you
and certainly certain stimuli that
usually induce the stress response can
lead to activation of virus replication
latent infection reactivation you go
back and you start lytic infection your
pustule that results your cold sore
results from lytic infection of
epidermal cells and dermal cells beneath
it to some extent now contrast this to
some extent with chicken pox and
shingles chicken pox virus
varicella-zoster is acquired either
through the conduct timer or through the
respiratory tract replication is
believed to occur in primary lymph nodes
right up in the throat after four to six
days sufficient mass of viruses are made
so that you have a primary fire emia so
the virus is spreading throughout the
body in its first course and it lands in
the liver the spleen and other target
organs where it replicates some more and
you have a secondary viremia so it's not
one was simply not enough and it's the
second viremia where the virus spreads
to the skin and that's when you see the
waves of development of chicken pox how
many of you have had chicken pox
Wow amazing how many of you have
vaccinated one two three all right so
for the most part people your age should
have been vaccinated well never mind
the vaccination is a difficult procedure
it's very difficult to get high titer
virus and that the companies that make
it merkins and SmithKline Glaxo have had
problems getting very high titer
vaccines and as a result kids get
immunized twice with it now or more
recently it's been shown that these
vaccines are very efficacious to those
of us who were slightly older and who
may or may not have had chickenpox you
rarely get a second case of chickenpox
but you do get shingles as you advance
past the age of 55 the occurrence of
shingles increases and we believe that
because the t memory cells go to hell
after about 50 years so you lose your
immune response
so people get boosted and there's now a
vaccine for that anyways we have this
secondary viremia you get infection of
the epidermal cells and you get the
characteristic rash and little pox and
they then spread to the sensory neurons
there's no evidence that the sympathetic
neurons are infected though I find it
hard to believe that they escaped again
that's my prejudice anyways they go and
do what simplex does and they sit in the
ganglia so these are
immunohistochemistry pictures of human
ganglia that have been sectioned and
surveyed for the presence of
varicella-zoster virus proteins when we
note that in the skin when you look for
vzv proteins this protein in particular
or 29 p it doesn't matter what it is is
found in the nucleus and it's protein
that's required for DNA replication
so here's orphe 29 in a neuron body and
you'll note that the nucleus has nothing
in it all of the protein that is present
in this neuronal body is present in the
cytoplasm as is a protein called or 2160
362 and 4 and all of these are
regulatory proteins that the virus
elicits during its normal course of
productive infection the difference is
those proteins are found in the nucleus
where the virus does its dirty work and
they're not found in the nucleus in
neurons in neurons so there are five of
these virus specified proteins each is a
regulatory protein that controls our the
gene expression of DNA replication and
they're apparently localized now
epstein-barr virus is a gamma herpes
virus 95% of adults are seropositive
carry the genome how many of you had
mononucleosis you can't say you've been
to college unless you've had mono
alright the virus resides and
persistently infected non proliferating
B lymphocytes and it's the causal agent
of all of these different cancers and it
does that because it goes latent and it
changes the cell programs and causes
these cells to replicate under unusual
conditions the EBV lifestyle is and this
is just one example of it so don't
commit this whole thing to memory
because there's more to it than that
what I'd like you to recognize is that
in a primary infection and we're
starting up here in saliva because
that's the normal portal of entry and
mono mononucleosis for years was caused
was called kissing disease because I was
how it was most evidently transmitted so
you get infection of epithelial cells
where the virus is thought to replicate
poorly but get to resting b-cells and
it's there where the virus really finds
its great happiness it goes in it
synthesizes a few proteins and it can
either replicate and if it elaborates
both a latent membrane protein one and a
latent memory protein 2 and other EBV
proteins then CTLs will see it killer
cells will see it and the infected cell
will
be killed and maybe virus or be released
and the virus is released
you can go back affect more b-cells and
then you sometimes see a different kind
of an infection where only this protein
Avenue one epstein-barr virus nuclear
antigen and lmp2 are found lmp2 is a
stealth protein so it's found along the
surface of a cell in the outer membrane
but so little of the protein is exposed
that it's not recognized by CTLs and
these cells can live very happily with
epsilon by a virus very quietly and
what's an oil they get activated to make
virus and the virus comes back out
through the oropharynx and contaminates
your saliva and the next person you kiss
in latent ly infected B cells the virus
chromosome is a separate
self-replicating episome it associates
with nucleosomes it's methylated like
normal cell DNA is at CPG residues so it
looks a lot like the host for the most
part it expresses lmp2 and one of those
edna guys and these cells home to bone
marrow and lymphoid organs and rest
there they're not seen by CTLs or virus
specific antibody because the only thing
on this surface is this stealth protein
alum p2 but villians are produced in a
very small fraction of the cells those
are the guys that get reactivated and so
they get spread I told you before there
are multiple forms of EBV latency and it
turns out that they do different things
to the host in some case they produce
having two one and those small eavers
those small RNAs that are actually Paul
3 transcripts sometimes they produce
these guys and lmp1 and lmp2 in other
micro rnas and sometimes you have a
third types where they do all of the
above
plus the protein called Edna 2 Edna LP
and these activate host cyclones and
once you activate a host cyclin you turn
the cell onto replication and you
promote cell division
so one of the ways in which monoclonal
human antibodies were first made was to
activate b-cells
was to infect B cells that were plasma
cells with EBV and select for those that
proliferated and they would over express
the antibody that they were synthesizing
so what happens when the B cell divides
the episome virus genome has to
replicate to be distributed to daughter
cells and it has to replicate in
synchrony with a host again if the host
divides the virus really wants to be in
both of those cells both the parental
cell and the daughter cell and it's
evolved a very very interesting way of
using the host to control that it has
two origins for DNA replication one ori
lid is used for lytic replication that's
when the virus needs to make high copy
numbers of virus lots of genomes the
other or EP is used for episomal
replication and latent ly infected cells
low copy numbers of virus genomes so
replication of this whole thing as I
told you has to be synchronized with the
host we know why it's to preserve its
genome in the different cells or EP is
normally quiescent so this origin that's
used to replicate in lately infected
cells is not used during little
implication and the reason that its
quiescent is it's bound by host
regulatory proteins that block EBV DNA
replication and EBV elaborates a protein
called Edna one which is a nuclear
antigen which binds DNA and once bound
to DNA it interacts with host proteins
to form a stable complex in origin
replication complex or an ork this
replication that occurs in lately
infected cells is in synchrony with a
host so you remember M s g1 g2 all those
guys that are extremely pertinent to how
EBV
replicates
so replication is said to be licensed by
the formation of this origin replication
complex and what happens is host
regulators are released and virus DNA
initiation occurs the host proteins that
are involved in controlling both
initiation and repression are
synthesized and degraded as a result of
the host cell going through the normal
replication cycle and cell division
cycle and this is a picture of what goes
on and what we refer to as replication
licensing in M in mitosis the FCM bore
virus genome is bound by this origin
replication complex during the course of
M there's a protein called gemenon which
binds another host protein these are all
host proteins now CD T 1 and as M
progresses gemenon is degraded CD T 1 is
released and one of the cell division us
cell cycle division protein C dc-6 which
is a protein kinase is also synthesized
in g1 these are brought to the origin
replication complex and they form a more
complex complex if you will and they act
as an attractant for another set of host
proteins called MCM MCM binds to the DNA
brought to it by this complex of
proteins between the orc and C D T 1 and
C T C 6 and forms a prin pre replication
complex once this complex forms during
g1 the cell enters s and s signals CD C
6 to phosphorylate proteins on the
origin replication complex and gemenon
is released with CD T 1 you now have
what for all essential purposes looks
like your sv40 replication origin so you
have bi-directional replication of this
very large 190 kilobase genome and
release
of CDC six which in g2 is degraded
release of MCM which enters the
cytoplasm and gets phosphorylated and
inactivated and gemenon taking CDT one
habit as the cell goes back into M we
see that CDT one is released from
gemenon it gets degraded and the whole
process starts over again
so that's replication licensing allowing
the virus genome to replicate coordinate
ly and concurrently with host
chromosomes hhv-6 is a beta herpes virus
and it's a causal agent of a very mild
childhood disease called example su vida
and everybody's got it everybody is Sara
positive for it the virus has been found
to persist in T cells and it infects the
host for life but unlike the other
herpes viruses that we've talked about
iam EBV CMV vzv HSV there are no
circular episomal forms in fact what's
found is that the virus genome
integrates into telomeres so those very
ends of the chromosomes that have
duplicated regions of DNA and the reason
for that is that it has sequences that
are very similar to it and it's a very
easy pathway for it to get in and it can
also get out so it can be reactivated in
response to certain molecules and
probably also in response to immune
suppression so this strategy of lodging
yourself at the ends of virus
chromosomes makes the integration of
plausible molecular strategy for viral
latency and in fact it's one that's
import used by some of the polyomavirus
now there are over a hundred distinct
types of human papilloma viruses we now
have a vaccine that protects against
most of the types that are involved in
formation of cervical and uterine cancer
and that's good they don't protect
against everything
but these viruses segregate into what we
call mucocutaneous and cutaneous sites
types that is they infect mucocutaneous
areas the gentle areas or regular skin
dry and wet surfaces and in each
instance there are both high and low
risk types and what I mean by that is
low risk types form warts benign
papillomas high risk types have a
predilection towards causing cells to be
driven into the cancer type cancer
phenotype that doesn't mean that they
survive or that all of them go on to
form malignant infections but there is
some incidents when a papilloma virus
enters the skin by the the cutaneous of
mucocutaneous surface it infects the
basal layer so all the way down right
where the epithelium starts and right at
the surface the junction of the dermis
and it first replicates as episomes as
cells divide remember that your skin
being the largest organ in your body
also turns itself over quite frequently
and that's a result of these basal cells
dividing and the replication they
replicate as theta forms so instead of
coming out in those big molecules the
way we talked about us before T and
Pollione homo viruses they don't
replicate bi-directionally it's just in
one direction so it's unidirectional the
viruses replicate their genomes and make
proteins only in terminally
differentiated epithelial cells and
these are cells that gets left off when
they're going to become when they're
let's see how am I going to put this
when they're not replicating that is
when they get into cells and they get
integrated into the virus into the host
chromosome and you see changes
dysplasias in cells that is they don't
look normal
they have the capacity to divide in
places where they don't normally do so
it's not just the basal cells anymore
that are dividing it's those in the
stratified epithelium what happens is
the chromosome the viol chromosome
into the host and that interrupts the
program of terminal differentiation of
the host because of the expression of
these two proteins and these two
proteins act to interfere with cell
cycle regulators so they push these
cells from being limited in terms of
replication and being focused on
differentiating into being replicating
cells so this is what it looks like
here's your skin and here's that basal
lamina and the precursor skin cells
these are pluripotent stem cells so they
have the capacity to become many other
tissue types many other tissue types but
more importantly their self-renewing so
each time they divide they give rise to
a mother and the daughter and each time
they divide they push the layer that's
above them up further and as these cells
get pushed up into the further and
further into the epidermis they begin to
differentiate they flatten their nuclei
begin to decrease in size and a whole
different program of cell surface
proteins that lead to the elaboration of
keratin assume is is initiated in these
more differentiated skin cells is where
the virus normally replicates when it's
undergoing lytic infection in the case
where the virus actually gets integrated
then these cells acquire the capacity to
replicate by themselves so they're no
longer terminally differentiated and
they can spread and cause a lesion
papillomavirus persistence intact virus
genomes persist in basal cells are
developing epithelium the genomes divide
is episomes with a host again just like
epstein-barr virus each time that cell
gives rise to a daughter cell that virus
genome gets passed on infectious virus
is not present except in the stratified
part of the epithelium
in developing cancers the genome is
integrated it replicates only when the
host cell divides again it's point and
parcel of the host chromosome and virus
proteins such as e 67 and a membrane
protein C 5 are expressed the air are a
family of viruses known as the human
polyomavirus known members of this and
they have these great names the V always
stands for virus by the way and the
other things stand for something
probably where they're discovered or I
don't know what but most of these can
actually cause tumors and animal models
does that mean that caused tumors in man
only Merkel cell virus is associated
with a human tumor the other human
polyomavirus is appear to latent li
infect people and for the most part
that's rather benign but what did I do
no that's no good
okay it turns out that people who have
JC or BK or frequently fancy go - excuse
me it's not frequent or found sometimes
to go on to develop a disease called
progressive multifocal
leukoencephalopathy remember that was
the what you got to say this on the way
out for your final and under these
conditions myelin is lost and not
replaced by our go tender sites the
nerves become damaged and everything
stops working properly and we've seen
around a higher instance of it lately
because people with multiple sclerosis
have been treated with an
immunosuppressive antibody called the
Sabri and so this is a balancing act we
know that most people have these viruses
in them and we know that in most
instances treatment with this antibody
does not result in reactivation of
viruses but in a finite number of cases
it does and they develop PML so that's a
sad state it's going to get them either
the disease is going to get them or PML
is but the bottom line is - sovery is a
very effective drug when it's working
properly so a famous guy in a blog in
2009 said given the high serum
prevalence of polymer viruses in humans
it is not surprising that there are
significant pathogens in
immunosuppressed populations an
important question is why these viruses
can peacefully coexist in many humans
without causing disease are human poly
Oma's Palermo viruses simply passengers
or do they benefit us in some unknown
way and that can be said for almost any
virus in which we talk about latency so
let me finish with something that was
found a couple of years ago this Merkel
cell carcinoma was actually found and
discovered by the same people who
discovered Kaposi sarcoma herpes virus
and it turns out for all the world and
the reason that you can't read it is
because it's not important
treated just remember that it's a
circular molecule and what I want you to
know is that it makes a large T antigen
a molecule that's homologous or tholly
goes in this case to the sv40 T antigen
that molecule that does everything does
replication it does transcription does
cell transformation and when you look at
it on a phylogenetic tree you see that
it's really not that close to the other
human papillomaviruses rather it's a
little bit closer and off of a tree in
which African green monkey murine in
hamster came and that tells you
absolutely nothing what is interesting
about this virus though is that in
tumors when the virus is present in
Merkel's cell is a very rare tumor of
neuroectodermal origin and it evolves
from the Merkel cell which is a Makenna
Makenna sensory receptor and what we see
is that virus DNA is integrated in a
clonal pattern that means one cell got
infected and expanded so the integration
site is some novel place in the cell
genome so infection and integration
preceded clonal expansion of the tumor
cell the other thing that's interesting
is that all MCV positive tumors have
mutations in t antigen so they don't
have fully profession proficient Tanager
molecules and therefore their
replication deficient so when the
mutation occurred is not clear but we
know that the integrated virus genomes
cannot be excised and that the cells
survive because the virus doesn't
replicate so let me finish with this
thought about persistence and that is
that virus is preferentially target
slowly dividing or non-dividing cells to
host their latent genomes because it's
the best place to hide if they're
selling doing anything it's going to be
left alone for the most part they did op
adopt a variety of survival strategies
that coordinate replication of their
genomes an expression from these genomes
to allow them to persist and in response
to a variety of
Tim you lie these Layton genomes can on
occasion reactivate thank you